all right so we always try to close out
with something we hope we make you smile
here's what I'm
[Applause]
[Music]
liking there are so many amazing movies
people watch every year one of my
favorites that I literally watch every
year with my kids is the sound of music
I love it so much amen that's I know yes
and we have the woman who played one of
the youngest Von trap girls in the movie
Bita dialed in so let's say hi to Angela
cartrite everybody
hello it's such a cool thing to have you
on the show thank you for joining us
great to be here awesome so you were 10
when you filmed it so did you think then
were you just being a kid did you know
it was going to blow up like that did
you think that movie was going to be
huge no we had no idea we just knew that
we were having a blast doing this movie
and um it was just an experience but we
had no idea that you know it's almost
been 60 years now
and this movie is still going strong I
know you know what you say that but
literally every night my seven-year-old
son while I like draw on his back he
makes me sing the suage song DOI I have
to sing DOI that whole song every night
like while I scratch his back it's any s
and it was over 60 years ago the film
was released what a pop culture impact
that movie has had so there's a new
super deluxe version of The Sound of
Music soundtrack coming out in February
it features 40 previously unreleased
tracks from the film which is so
cool so very cool and I'm taking this um
so out of these that's never been done
before the this is just the soundtrack
and it has all the music from you know
all the scenes even the parts that we're
not singing um and so nobody's really
heard that except on the movie itself so
it's very very special it's lovely it
really is very special that's special I
love the behind the scenes nature of
this this is so cool like a film that's
so loved by so many families that's so
cool to get all of this now like later
in life the Super Deluxe Edition of the
sound of music is available on digital
platforms right now everybody and the
box set drops February 2nd it's
available for pre-order so reserve a
copy thank you so much for joining us
this is so cool I'm liking your post
right
now and generally at this point in the
show we give our guest $1,000 courtesy
of our season long partner pilot pin
makers of friction the go-to erasable
pen of the Kelly Clarkson show but I
think Angela's doing all right right
she's an actress she's been killing it
for decades she don't need this so she's
doing well for herself so we're gonna
give it to one of you does anybody want
,000 well look at our Monitor and
somebody's face is get to show up and
now she get cash let's do
it
yeah what wait what's what's your name
I'm Bailey you're Bailey yes what are
you going to do with a grand Bailey oh I
think I'm going to have to take a trip
somewhere because that's just a crazy
amount of money thank you people always
say pay bills that's nice but have some
fun with it thank you thank you for
coming Bailey thank you congrats on the
Grand and thank you to all our guests
this hour
J Maro Taylor Ruth Adam Woodworth and
rben Irving y'all have a great if it's
not
[Music]
[Applause]
changing thank you guys y have a great
night I'm going
home